a buoyant rendition of China's national
anthem opens its annual parliamentary
session in Beijing but outgoing Premier
League's assessment of the country's
economic performance was somber in
comparison
he said the pandemic and challenges in
the international environment had caused
China to fall short of its previous GDP
Target of 5.5 percent hitting only 3
percent
he announced a more modest goal for
growth in 2023
the main projected targets for
development this year are as follows GDB
growth of around five percent around 12
million new Urban jobs serving Urban
unemployment rate of around 5.5 percent
boosting income and consumer spending
are major priorities there will also be
a renewed focus on Innovation and
technological self-reliance beijing's
response to what it says are escalating
attempts by the United States and its
allies to suppress Chinese firms they're
pressing ahead on technology basically
to fill the void that is being created
by you know these embargoes by the
United States
um and and they're also very very keen
on reducing costs across the board they
want Chinese manufacturing to be lean
mean and at the lower end of the
spectrum they believe that this is the
key competitiveness is the key uh to
maintaining the markets China will also
boost its military preparedness and
increase its defense budget by 7.2
percent the Communist party is concerned
by increasing tensions around Taiwan a
self-ruled island claimed by Beijing Xi
Jinping says peaceful reunification is
preferred although he has not ruled out
the use of Force Beijing is also
troubled by the continuing war in
Ukraine tensions on the Korean Peninsula
and the rearming of Japan although it
denies targeting any third party
China's military modernization does not
pose a threat to any country but rather
is a positive force for maintaining
Regional stability and World Peace
this is Lika Chung's last recitation of
the annual Communist Party work report
as Premier a role he held for 10 years
Premier League was known for his
reform-minded approach to managing
China's economy he will be replaced by
Liu Chang a loyal supporter of student
teamed with limited International
experience analysts say this will likely
lead to a step back in the
liberalization of the economy and more
power being concentrated in the top
ranks of the Communist Party
training you Al Jazeera Beijing